dans plusieurs régions de France une
véritable course vers l'essence enfin
pour les automobilistes il s'agit plutôt
d'un exercice de patience
[Musique]
mais là j'étais obligé j'en suis à ma
quatrième pompe on est lundi fin
d'après-midi on se trouve devant l'une
des stations services de la Région
Parisienne on peut toujours se procurer
du carburant et elles seront plus en
plus rares même ici l'offre est limitée
et la situation est encore plus critique
dans le nord de la France ou la crise
perdure depuis plusieurs jours déjà
à l'île cette station la seule de la
ville qui n'était pas hors service était
très convoité lundi
que ça fait trois jours que j'arrête pas
de regarder l'application pour le
carburant pour descendre dans certaines
régions les transports scolaires ont été
diminués ou simplement interrompus à
travers le pays certains secteurs de
l'économie s'inquiètent des impacts de
la crise c'est par exemple le cas dans
le domaine de la santé on fait la queue
pendant demeure trois quarts d'heure une
heure pour faire le plein de gasoil de
nos véhicules qui doivent non pas perdre
du temps à faire du gasoil mais qui
doivent être là pour prendre en charge
des patients on est des salariés qui
exercent aujourd'hui un droit qui est
fondamental à l'origine de ces pénuries
des grèves dans les raffineries des
géants actuellement mobiles et total
énergie pour faire face à l'inflation
les travailleurs de Total demandent par
exemple une augmentation salariale de
7%, ils exigent un ajout supplémentaire
de 3% compte tenu des profits immenses
qu'à réaliser leur société l'inflation
tous les travailleurs se la prennent
total promettent de vincer les
discussions sur les salaires mais
seulement une fois que les activités
auront repris dans ces raffineries il
faut que les parties prenantes prennent
leur responsabilités les entreprises et
les chefs d'entreprise concernées et les
syndicats concernés le blocage c'est pas
une façon de négocier la grève a été
reconduite d'une journée pour l'instant
les négociations semblent difficilement
avancer on peut vous promettre tout
comme quoi ça va ça va reprendre ça va
rentrer dans l'ordre mais
rien de rien de concret les réserves
stratégiques du gouvernement ont été
mises à contribution mais à quand un
véritable dénouement à la table de
négociations sur les routes du pays ils
sont nombreux à se poser la question il
sera fait le bouvier au clair
Radio-Canada à Paris